lumières 2.0 ou bien tout simplement
lumière 1.0 bonjour je pense que vous
avez tous remarqué que les lasers arrive
d'une manière ou d'une autre par mille
facettes dans votre vie quotidienne
si vous allez au supermarché vos courses
sont comptabilisés par des petits lasers
si vous allez chez le médecin pour
tatouages peuvent être enlevés par laser
si vous écoutez de la musique dans votre
salon ou regarder un film c'est encore
un petit laser est au coeur de votre
lecteur de cd ou dvd
tous ces lasers là sont relativement
petit un petit peu que ce petit pointeur
laser ici mais il existe aussi des
lasers nettement plus grand plus
impressionnant qu'il reste relativement
mal connues et c'est pour cela que je
vous invite maintenant à une petite
promenade dans le paysage des grands
laser alors pour commencer
qu'est ce qu'un laser et qu'est ce que
la lumière la lumière ce d'abord des
petits grains d'énergie qu'on appelle
des photons alors les photons du monde
de tous les jours les photons du soleil
ou les photons de ses spots qui m'avait
blanc ce moment c'est typiquement des
grains de lumière d'énergie différentes
de couleurs différentes qui part dans
tous les sens quand ils veulent qu'ils
se croisent qui s'ignore regardons les
se voulait comme des écoliers dans les
cours d'école en pleine récréation ils
courent ils marchent ils chahutent il
crie simple des oeuvres et puis un
moment la maîtresse siffler c'est la fin
de la récréation et vous voyez tous ces
petits écoliers qui se met parente de
bien sage et qui rentrent tranquillement
en place pour un physicien les photons
c'est un peu nos enfants et des fils de
photons bien rangées bien ordonnée bien
prédictible ça s'appelle un laser alors
voici l'image classique que beaucoup de
gens ont d'un laser avec ce joli
faisceau rouge à ses caractéristiques on
a souvent vu dans nos salles de classe
les lasers dont moi je vais vous parler
dit
de celui là de deux grandes bannières
d'une part ils sont invisibles
c'est un peu paradoxal mais tout comme
l'oreille humaine n'entend pas les
ultrasons le human ne voit pas certaines
couleurs et manque de chance les lasers
de l'extrême fonctionne presque tous
avec une couleur invisible notre part
mais laser fonctionne non pas en continu
mais en appel si on va concentrer
l'énergie sur un laps de temps
relativement bref comment est ce
possible
c'est pas très compliqué sur le principe
simplement il faudrait inventer une
porte qui peut être juste l'action de
mon doigt sur un laser regarder l'écran
vous venez de voir une impulsion laser
d'une seconde
cette porte mécanique avec mon doigt
c'est lent on peut faire mieux
utilisons de l'électronique une bonne
électronique bien rapide vous créera une
porte qui ne dura qu'un milliardième de
seconde
vous pourrez créer les impulsions laser
d'un milliardième de seconde est en fait
depuis l'invention du laser 1960 et une
véritable course internationale à qui
aurait le laser le plus court que le
voisin pour cela donc ont été développés
d un grand nombre de techniques très
ingénieuse qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les
impulsions lasers des plus courtes ne
dure que quelques milles îles ioniennes
de milliardième de seconde alors c'est
un petit peu un composant pas très
commode de parler en permanence dans cet
exposé deux millionième de milliardième
de seconde
donc je vous propose d'utiliser le terme
du jargon la femto secundo donc une
scène toute seconde ce millionième de
milliardième de seconde c'est quoi
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'appréhender
pas le mieux c'est de revenir à la
vitesse de la lumière
quelle distance parcours la lumière en
une seule seconde on une seconde en une
seconde la lumière passe de la terre à
la lune distance absolument énorme la
lumière à quelque chose qui va
extraordinairement vite et bien en une
femto secondes
la lumière va simplement longer un petit
virus de 320 de m donc une fin de
seconde est à la seconde
ce que le virus ebola est à distance
terre-lune
une fois ces impulsions obtenu il va
falloir leur donner de l'énergie
alors pour ça on a développé pendant 55
ans énormément technique de technologie
que je vais vous expliquer en détails
maintenant voici le schéma d'une chaîne
laser développées par nos collègues aux
états unis en californie il ya quelques
années c'est un laser petal watts
le vrai laser le départ et laisser la
boîte numéro 2 et et j'espère que je
vous ai fait peur parce que je n'ai
surtout pas vous expliquer ce
transparent beaucoup trop compliqué en
fait mon but ici c'est vraiment de
montrer la complexité folle de la
technologie qu'on a été amené à
développer pour faire passer des
impulsions laser ta niveau initial clé
de l'ordre d'un milliardième de joules
un niveau final qui est de l'ordre du
jour voir le million de joules alors
juste une petite remarque le joule par
contre ce n'est peut-être notre monde
quotidien
si je prends une petite bouteille d'eau
et que je lève de 30 cm jeu délivrer un
travail d'un jour donc c'est une nuitée
à ses quotidiennes un million de joules
ça commence à faire pas mal et c'est
exactement le niveau d'énergie cattin le
laser mégajoule qui à l'avenir
développés par le cea au sud de bordeaux
à côté d'ici au bar 30 km au sud d'ici
vous avez ici une photo du bâtiment du
laser qui fait juste 300 mètres de long
une photo d'un des quatre au laser dans
laquelle passe 172 6 au total
en bas à gauche vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la chambre l'interaction
l'endroit où tu sais s'en sont tous les
souvenirs se focaliser leur petite
remarque en passant peut-être des
cinéphiles dans la salle ceux d'entre
vous qui aiment le cinéma et la
science-fiction connaissent peut-être un
film qui s'appelle star trek into
darkness dans ce film le capitaine kirk
se sacrifie pour sauver son équipage en
se laissant irradié sont une espèce
d'immense bull à cette boulette tout à
fait réelle parce que c'est sa soeur
jumelle qui installé en californie et
nouveaux qui étaient utilisés pour les
besoins du tournage de de sart trek en
bas à droite vous avez le petit point
central au milieu de la boule sur lequel
viendront se focaliser ses 172 faisceau
alors une énergie
importante en un intervalle de temps
extrêmement court
on va parler en termes de puissance et à
nouveau je vais le même problème que
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que une
puissance habituelle c'est le wat mais
là je vais être amené à parler en
millions de milliards de watts a pas
pratique du tout donc faisons un petit
point sur ces puissances à la maison si
vous utilisez une bouilloire elle va
consommer environ un millier de watts
c'est à dire un kilowatt si vous avez
surtout à la campagne et vous avez le
malheur de travail côté d'une éolienne
celle ci va délivrer environ 1 mégawatt
si vous êtes à côté d'une centrale
nucléaire une tranche de centrale
nucléaire elle délivrera un gigawatt
donc un milliard de watts 1000 et
éolienne est bien le plus modeste
un modeste laser comme le laser aurore
que nous avons juste à côté 10 yens
diversité délivrera lui des impulsions
de l'ordre de 1 tera watt soit
l'équivalent de 1000 centrales
nucléaires et les projets laser les plus
ambitieux aujourd'hui comme le laser
apollon en ile de france ou le laser
petal en aquitaine le vise le péta watts
c'est à dire un million de centrales
nucléaires normalement à ce moment-là
vous devriez vous dire que cette espèce
de conférencier vous dis n'importe quoi
parce que clairement on n'a pas un
million de centrales nucléaires derrière
le laser la grosse différence c'est que
en hausse que vous avez ce dispositif
qui fonctionne en continu alors que le
laser à nouveau et délivre des
impulsions extraordinairement brève et
donc c'est en concentrant l'énergie sont
en cours on arrive à des puissances
aussi extraordinaire c'est puissance on
veut maintenant les concentrer sur des
tâches extrêmement petit sur des zones
de l'ordre de quelques microns à
quelques centaines de micro m hélas la
matière va pas rester gentiment l'état
de molécules ou d'atomes très longtemps
les électrons votre être arrachés mais
alors en beaucoup moins qu'une
femtoseconde et on va arriver tout de
suite à ce quatrième état de la matière
qu'on appelle l'état de placements à
l'échelle de l'univers c'est l'état qui
est dominante de loin c'est plasma
peuvent être extrêmement faut quand j'ai
créé deux manches ça veut dire qu'ils
atteignent des dizaines de milliers de
degrés pour les plus froids et environ 1
milliard de degrés pour les plus chauds
vous imaginez bien qu'on a tout un tas
de phénomènes qui vont se produire à ce
niveau là avec apparition des champs
électriques de chambre
étiqueté électrons de propos de plein de
choses phénomène qui va falloir
maintenant utiliser pourquoi à quoi ça
sert tout ça pour nous dit tous les
jours de notre génération
à mon avis à rien par contre pour les
générations de nos enfants nos
petits-enfants
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
possibilités parmi les dizaines de
phénomène que je pourrais citer que nous
étudions en vue d'applications réelles
je vais encore j'en ai choisi 3 la
première étant l'accélération
d'électrons par laser alors imaginez
vous preniez un laser d'énergie
raisonnable environ un joule mais
concentraient donc ont duré cours
d'environ 30 femtoseconde et que vous la
concentré sur un petit jet des lionnes
le laser il va traverser l'hélium il va
même pas s'apercevoir qu'il y avait
quelque chose
pas par contre chemin faisant il va
évidemment arraché trois électrons qui
voit et puis on constate
expérimentalement qu'à la sortie du jet
de gaz le laser est suivie d'un paquet
d'électrons chacun doté d'une énergie
cinétique extraordinairement élevé quand
j'ai premièrement élevé on peut
atteindre plusieurs centaines de méga
les troncs volts ou de gigaélectron volt
alors c'est pas forcément une unité à
nouveau qui vous dit beaucoup faut juste
savoir que le plus grand accélérateur du
monde le let à genève qui fonctionne et
une quinzaine d'années atteignez lui 100
gigaélectronvolts ça veut dire que sur
quelques millimètres ou cm
d'accélération on atteint typiquement un
vingtième de ce que faisaient nos
collègues de genève sur un anneau de
27km de circonférence
là il ya une application directe
possible qui est le fait que pour la
physique fondamentale particules on peut
va pas construire des accélérateurs de
100 km de circonférence ou 2000 km de
circonférence
par contre grâce à nos champs
accélérateur dix mille fois plus fort on
pourrait imaginer que les accélérateurs
du futur soit basé sur ces 7
ce mécanisme alors ça a l'air un peu
magique comme ça j'en vois laser et push
des électrons qui arrive
essayons de regarder un petit peu ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe c'est que le
laser cohérente dans le jet de gaz il va
jouer aux chasse neige
c'est à dire qu'il ya une voie des
électrons devant lui c'est moi le laser
poussez-vous les petits gars ils
envoient tous les électrons d'abord sur
le vers l'avant puis sur le côté une
fois que le laser est passé les
électrons sur le coup
ils vont juste revenir en arrière et
donc induire ce qu'on appelle une vague
un sillage
et entre temps l'ensemble aura laissé
une bulle complètement vide d'électrons
milieu c'est ce que vous voyez en blanc
ici cette bulle est chargé plutôt
positivement les électrons sont chargées
négativement donc dans cette bulle vous
avez des champs électriques
extraordinairement intense qui apparaît
spontanément et si vous êtes un électron
qui par chance ou malchance aux dépens
des points de vue est situé juste en
arrière de la bulle
il va être complètement tirée vers le
centre de la bulle qu'on se fasse
commencent à se déplacer très rapidement
suivre le laser qui lui se propage et
puis je suis nazi refus il accéléré et
c'est ainsi qu'en sortie de jets de gaz
on arrive à véritable paquet d'électrons
à des énergies très importante donc de
manière imagée tout se passe comme si le
laser ici était un hors-bord sur un lac
qui crée une vague de sciage et que les
électrons et et des surfeurs plutôt doué
qui surf sur la vague de sciage gaye à
leur bord jusqu'à en fait rattraper le
matin donc c'est mon premier rêve d
accélérateur du futur sont ils seront
ils à base de laser
oui arrivé 2e d'application possible
accélération de protons alors il ya
plusieurs mécanismes possibles pour ça
que j'ai choisi de vous montrer un
mécanisme un peu extrêmes qu'ils
retireraient des lasers encore plus
intense confocale est vrai sur des
feuilles de plastique extrêmement mince
on va avoir le même effet chasse-neige
que tout à leur malheur encore plus fort
c'est à dire que cette fois ci non
seulement le laser va pousser tous les
électrons vers l'avant mais il va même
pousser tous les protons et où les
carbone vers l'avant que vous voyez ici
c'est les les protons à ventiler carbone
qui reste un petit peu derrière parce
qu'ils sont un peu plus lourd on peut
atteindre normalement d énergie de
quelques dizaines mais galec tron volts
alors ça par contre pour un physicien
d'accélérateur c'est impressionnant du
tout pour un proton ce qui advient teint
contre c'est que cette énergie là est
complètement dans la gamme qui intéresse
les médecins pour une des variantes de
la radiothérapie du cancer qu'on appelle
la protonthérapie normalement la
protonthérapie pense à d'énormes
avantages ce qui limite l'application de
la protonthérapie c'est le fait que
l'accélération de protons ça c'est pas
très bonne grosse histoire
par contre pour amener des protons
accélérés sur la tête d'un patient sur
un an bien précis on a besoin de
véritables cathédrale de béton et
d'acier qui coûte très cher ici on
pourrait avoir un laser certes un petit
peu gros mais ensuite peut-être
transporté dans la direction qu'on veut
par des miroirs mais on fait la
conversion laser au thon au plus près du
patient rêve numéro 2 la protonthérapie
du futur se rappelle à base de laser
partons maintenant dans l'infiniment
grand
ce que je vous montre ici c'est des
photos de gel de plasma interstellaire
qu'on appelle des objets herbig haro
sont des photos prises par le télescope
spatial hubble
il s'agit en fait d'un phénomène dans
lequel devient un jeu plasmas chauds qui
en fait traverse un plasma froid donc
vous avez une collision de plasma et à
l'endroit de cette collision se
développent une structure très
particulière qu'on appelle un choc
d'étrave alors les dimensions sont
astronomiques par définition
imaginez vous que l'ensemble notre
système solaire c'est à l'intérieur d'un
des petits points blancs d'image des
toiles que vous voyez là donc évidemment
à notre échelle humaine c'est qu'un
processus extrêmement longue
immobile
tout ce qu'on peut faire c'est prendre
des images par contre avec un laser on
sait reproduire le phénomène
à notre échelle en créant déjà de
plasmas chauds qui traverse un milieu
froid et donc on reproduit complètement
la dynamique de ses jets plasma de ces
chocs et raf là on utilise le principe
de similarité bien sûr les ordres de
grandeur des espaces et de temps sont
complètement différents mais la physique
fondamentale est la même on choisit aps
les paramètres pour soit la même c'est
cette similarité ce qui nous amène
directement à beaucoup d'un trop plein
d'autres applications des lasers
intenses
en fait les conditions concret au foyer
des lasers sont telles qu'on ne peut les
retrouver dans l'univers que au coeur
des étoiles ou coeur des galaxies et
donc raisonner en termes d'énergie toute
l'énergie que nous consommons sur terre
vient très largement du pétrole qui
lui-même de l'énergie de photosynthèse
il ya quelques millions d'années c'est
l'énergie du soleil si nous pouvions
reproduire cette fois le mécanisme de
création d'énergie du soleil même dans
des centrales s'assurerait
essentiellement nous réserve de
l'énergie quasi inépuisable est libre
tout carbone selon le numéro 3
la question de la fusion nucléaire
contrôlée c'est un des sujets qui sera
étudiée sur le laser mj et leurs pétales
au sud de bordeaux
pouvons-nous contrôler le processus de
création d'énergie des étoiles alors
prenons un petit peu de hauteur
maintenant en tant que physicien 30
chercheurs
qu'est ce que nous sommes en train de
faire est ce que nous sommes en train de
d'essayer de comprendre les lois de la
nature qui nous entoure à notre échelle
la réponse est non
ces lois là ils sont connus depuis des
dizaines d'années est ce que nous sommes
en train de marier la physique à
d'autres disciplines comme la géologie
ou la biologie la médecine
non c'est une approche très fructueuse
mais c'est pas celle que nous suivons
ici ce que nous faisons c'est de marier
la technologie la plus avancée la
recherche fondamentale
nous créons des objets technologiques
sont des lasers extrêmement intense ces
objets nous permettent de planter la
matière des conditions qu'on ne connaît
pas du tout sur terre
cela crée des phénomènes que l'on doit
découvrir d'abord
étudiez comprendre peu à peu contrôlées
et enfin peut-être utilisé c'est le sens
des trois rêves successifs que vous ai
présenté un rêve pour l'application de
ces lasers en sciences fondamentales
un rêve leurs applications en médecine
un rêve pour leurs applications sociétal
pour l'énergie mais un des pères du
laser fraîcheur charles stone ce qui
nous a malheureusement quittés il ya
deux mois
rappelait dans cette conclusion il ya
quelques années pour à l'occasion des 50
ans du laser que toute l'histoire du
laser montrent que les principales
applications sont arrivés de manière
complètement inattendue et donc il est
tout à fait possible que de ce que je
vous ai présenté
rien ne débouche il est tout à fait
possible que de nouvelles applications
émergent et s'impose et donc que quelque
part
le laser dépasse le rêve
merci